cada vez que usted fuma un cigarrillo
los gases tóxicos pasan a sus pulmones y
luego a su torrente sanguíneo desde
donde se diseminan a cada órgano de su
cuerpo
un cigarrillo se fabrica a partir de
hojas de tabaco las cuales contienen
nicotina y una variedad de otros
compuestos
a medida que el tabaco y los compuestos
se queman liberan miles de sustancias
químicas peligrosas incluyendo más de 40
comprobadas como causantes de cáncer el
humo del cigarrillo contiene gases
venenosos como monóxido de carbono y
óxido de nitrógeno así como pequeñas
cantidades de partículas radioactivas
causantes de cáncer
todos los tipos de tabaco son peligrosos
incluyendo los cigarros pipas y el
tabaco sin humo así como el tabaco de
mascar y el rape
y la nicotina es una sustancia adictiva
presente en el tabaco después de inhalar
el humo del tabaco la nicotina fluye por
el torrente sanguíneo hacia el cerebro
donde provoca una sensación placentera
cuando usted expone su cerebro de manera
repetida a la nicotina éste se
desensibiliza motivo por el cual se le
antoja cada vez más nicotina para
sentirse normal
fumar causa la muerte las personas que
fuman suelen morir a una edad más
temprana que los no fumadores de hecho
uno de cada cinco muertes en los eeuu
está vinculada al consumo de cigarrillos
si usted fuma su riesgo de sufrir
problemas serios de salud aumenta de
forma dramática incluyendo enfermedades
cardíacas ataque o infarto al corazón
accidente cerebrovascular cáncer de
pulmón y muerte por enfermedad pulmonar
obstructiva crónica
fumar causa enfermedades
cardiovasculares
cuando la nicotina fluye a través de las
glándulas suprarrenales estimula la
liberación de epinefrina una hormona que
eleva la presión arterial
además la nicotina y el monóxido de
carbono pueden dañar el revestimiento de
las paredes internas de las arterias
pueden formarse depósitos de grasa
llamados placas en los sitios de estas
lesiones y crecer lo suficiente para
estrechar las arterias y reducir
drásticamente el flujo de sangre dando
lugar a una afección llamada
ateroesclerosis
en las cardiopatías coronarias la
ateroesclerosis estrecha las arterias
que irrigan el corazón lo que reduce el
suministro de oxígeno al músculo
cardíaco aumentando el riesgo de sufrir
un ataque o infarto al corazón
[Música]
fumar también aumenta el riesgo de
coágulos de sangre ya que hace que las
plaquetas en la sangre se agrupen
fumar aumenta el riesgo de enfermedad
vascular periférica en la que las placas
ateroscleróticas bloquean las arterias
grandes de los brazos y piernas
fumar también puede causar aneurisma de
la aorta abdominal qué es una
inflamación o debilitamiento de la aorta
en su sección abdominal
fumar daña dos de las partes principales
de los pulmones las vías respiratorias
también llamadas tubos bronquiales y los
pequeños sacos de aire llamados alveolos
con cada respiración el aire viaja por
el conducto respiratorio llamado tráquea
y entra en los pulmones a través de los
tubos bronquiales entonces el aire se
dirige a miles de pequeños alvéolos
donde el oxígeno del aire se mueve hacia
el torrente sanguíneo el dióxido de
carbono de desecho sale del torrente
sanguíneo
y minúsculas proyecciones similares al
cabello llamadas cilios revisten los
tubos bronquiales y barren las
sustancias nocivas fuera de los pulmones
y el humo del cigarrillo irrita el
revestimiento de los tubos bronquiales
haciendo que se hinchen y produzcan
mucosidad
y el humo del cigarrillo también hace
más lento el movimiento de sus cilios
provocando que un poco de humo y la
mucosidad permanezcan en los pulmones
mientras usted duerme algunos de los
cilios se logran recuperar y empiezan a
empujar a los contaminantes y el moco
fuera de los pulmones
cuando usted se despierta su cuerpo
trata de expulsar este material tosiendo
repetidamente una condición conocida
como tos de fumador con el tiempo se
desarrolla la bronquitis crónica debido
a que sus cilios dejan de trabajar sus
vías respiratorias se obstruyen con
cicatrices y moco y la respiración se
vuelve difícil sus pulmones son ahora
más vulnerables a otras enfermedades el
humo del cigarrillo también daña los
alvéolos haciendo más difícil el
intercambio de oxígeno y dióxido de
carbono hacia y desde la sangre
con el tiempo muy poco oxígeno puede
llegar a la sangre por lo que usted
puede desarrollar enfisema afección en
la que se respira con dificultad y se
debe usar un tubo de oxígeno en la nariz
para poder respirar
la bronquitis crónica y el enfisema son
conocidos de manera colectiva como
enfermedades pulmonares obstructivas
crónicas o ep
la epc es una pérdida gradual de la
capacidad respiratoria que no tiene cura
el humo del cigarrillo contiene al menos
40 sustancias causantes de cáncer
llamadas carcinógenos incluyendo el
cianuro formaldehído benceno y amoníaco
en su cuerpo crece en células sanas
producen nuevas células se reproducen y
luego mueren el material genético dentro
de cada célula llamado adn dirige este
proceso
si usted fuma las sustancias químicas
tóxicas pueden dañar el adn de las
células sanas
como resultado las células dañadas crean
nuevas células no saludables que crecen
fuera de control y se pueden extender a
otras partes del cuerpo
el cáncer más común a nivel mundial es
el cáncer de pulmón con más de un millón
de casos nuevos diagnosticados cada año
y las sustancias químicas nocivas de los
cigarrillos pueden causar cáncer en
otras partes del cuerpo tales como en la
sangre y médula ósea boca laringe
garganta esófago estómago páncreas
riñón
y vejiga útero
y cuello uterino
fumar puede causar infertilidad tanto en
hombres como en mujeres
si una mujer está embarazada y fuma
durante el embarazo expone a su bebé a
las sustancias químicas tóxicas del
cigarrillo que causan un mayor riesgo de
bajo peso al nacer aborto involuntario
parto prematuro muerte fetal muerte
infantil y el síndrome de muerte súbita
del lactante
fumar también es peligroso si la madre
está amamantando la nicotina pasa al
bebé por la leche materna y puede causar
inquietud
taquicardia
vómitos sueño interrumpido o diarrea
y otros efectos nocivos del hábito de
fumar para la salud son baja densidad
ósea y mayor riesgo de fractura de
cadera entre las mujeres enfermedad de
las encías que a menudo conduce a la
pérdida de dientes y a la cirugía
disfunción del sistema inmunológico y
curación lenta de las heridas e
impotencia sexual en los hombres